[Musique]
tout juste avant la pose des fêtes le
ministre fédéral de la Justice a annoncé
qu'il souhaitait reporter
l'élargissement de l'aide médicale à
mourir pour les personnes souffrant de
troublement taux la loi de ventrer en
vigueur le 17 mars mais David le métier
estime qu'il faut plus de temps pour
mieux préparer les provinces et les
professionnels de la santé à traiter ces
cas plus complexes faut-il s'inquiéter
de l'impact Cora se délai j'ai posé la
question à la docteur monacocta elle est
psychiatres rocheux mais à présider un
groupe d'experts sur la question
[Musique]
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
vous êtes président du groupe d'experts
sur l'aide médicale à mourir et la
maladie mentale pourquoi c'est important
d'après votre groupe d'experts détendre
l'aide médicale à mourir aux gens qui
souffrent de troublement
mais ça c'est une question très
intéressante en fait notre mandat
n'était pas d'étudier la question de si
les personnes atteintes des troubles
mentaux devraient avoir l'accès mais
plutôt de recommander les mesures de
sauvetage les protocoles des directives
pour encadrer les pratiques en fait
suite à la décision dans le cas de
Truchon
cette décision à invalidé l'exigence
qu'une personne soit en fin de vie au
Québec ou que le monde naturel soit
raisonnablement prévisible il a pas
mentionné des diagnostics ou des
catégories de patients ou de demandeurs
donc cette décision à effectivement
ouvert la porte à toute personne qui a
une maladie grave et une cuire un peu
porte sa nature de faire une demande ok
mais c'était le gouvernement fédéral
dans son projet de loi
C7 qui a été adopté en mars 2021 qui a
introduit une exclusion pour des
personnes atteintes donc si on suit la
décision entre Truchon ces personnes ont
avaient le droit d'accès dans un premier
temps
exactement exactement
on joue dans un territoire où comment
fait-on par exemple pour distinguer
quelqu'un qui souffre de tremblement
taux de quelqu'un qui pourrait avoir
dépensé suicidaires comment on se penche
sur ce genre de trucs que j'aimerais
souligner c'est que les personnes at des
troubles mentaux on le doit de faire des
demandes maintenant il faut juste qu'ils
ont une autre trouble physique qui va
qualifier pour la même en fait n'importe
demandeur peu importe la nature de sa
maladie peut avoir des idées suicidaires
donc ce que je veux dire par cela c'est
que les cliniciens doivent déjà faire
face à ces questions ils sont pas
spécifiques aux personnes atteintes des
troubles mentaux donc je pense que le
question à poser et les questions que le
groupe d'experts a posé c'est mais
qu'est-ce que les cliniciens font
maintenant quand ils sont devant les cas
complexes ou quelqu'un a peut-être des
antécédents de faire des tentatives
suicidaires etc et est-ce qu'on peut
appliquer cette même raisonnement aux
patients qui ont une tremblement de
terre comme seul problème médical
invoqué parce que c'est c'est ça le seul
différent
mais ça c'est complexe quand même c'est
pas c'est pas un cancer c'est pas c'est
un trouble mental on définit ça comment
on dit oui là non là comment vont
l'aborde d'un point de vue éthique d'un
point de vue clinique mais je pense que
j'aimerais vous redonner la question
pourquoi est-ce que c'est plus
compliqué la demande quelqu'un qui a un
double troubipolaire versus quelqu'un
qui a un troubi polaire et un épilepsie
réfractaire donc je pense que c'est ça
les questions il faut poser mais
pourtant il y a une certaine
appréhension de la part de la société ou
de la part des gouvernements d'aller
dans cette direction-là vous rendez ça
très clair puis vous me rendez ça très
simple pourquoi ça semble être si
difficile pour le législateur mais c'est
une très bonne question en fait je ne
sais pas parce que dans les faits si on
va demander les personnes qui évaluent
ces domaines les médecins les epièces
qui sont impliqués dans ces comédiens
ils vont vous dire que depuis
l'invalidation de l'exigence fait une
vie à mon naturel raisonnablement
prévisible les cas de le volet 2 comme
c'est connu les patients qui sont pas en
ville peuvent être très complexes dans
exactement le même façon que le
gouvernement fédéral les membres de la
Société appréhendent pour les troubles
mentaux comme ça le problème donc en
fait il y a pas nécessairement des
grandes différences alors après ça je
pense que c'est une question de
perception
sur la part de la société
il peut avoir aussi
des enjeuxistigmates
où on pense que les mais je veux dire
que tout autre personne dans la société
est capable ou peuvent être capables de
prendre sa propre décision pour sa vie
mais pas quelqu'un de notre mental
vous vous planchez présentement sur des
normes réglementaires maintenant les
normes réglementaires c'est ça va
s'appliquer à au Collège des médecins
c'est de donner essentiellement les
directives la base c'est ça donc les
comme on sait les médicaments
à le système de soins de santé
l'instance qui a le mandat de dire c'est
quoi une pratique sécurité dans
l'intérêt public ce sont des ordres
professionnels et c'est eux qui ont le
droit de t'obliger leur membres les
médecins et les epièces dans ce cas de
faire certaines choses ou de ne pas
faire certaines choses et c'est pour ça
on se pointait vers eux dans notre
première recommandations on a dit plein
de choses dans notre rapport par rapport
les bonnes pratiques mais la première
recommandation était on demande le
gouvernement fédéral de travailler avec
les gouvernements provincial et
territoriales et les ordres
professionnels de rédiger des noms
qui vont s'appliquer au médecin
IPS en matière d'AMM pour des cas
complexes incluant la maladie mentale le
délai le délai que demande Ottawa il est
il cause quoi d'après vous il a quoi
comme impact sur les gens atteints de
troublement tout qui attendent ces
modifications là mais il y a
divers d'abord il faut rappeler
dans une première temps les personnes
souffrantes depuis longtemps qui a
épuisé tous les traitements que la
médecine a offrir tous les services tous
les interventions qui comptaient faire
une demande et avoir le droit juste
d'avoir le demande étudié et on parle
pas d'avoir la demande d'avoir un mm on
parle d'avoir le doigt d'avoir son
demande étudiée donc eux ils peuvent
plus le faire
et je m'inquiète aussi sur l'impact sur
les personnes atteintes des troubles
mentaux en général
dans les yeux de la société
où on peut dire
sont pas si importants on n'a pas besoin
de tenir notre promesse on peut juste
facilement dire on reporte le doigt donc
je m'inquiète comme ces cases sur le
message que ça envoie
envers les personnes atteintes des
troubles mentaux et le doigt comme tout
autre membre de la Société
merci beaucoup merci à vous